en 1949 la vespière était aussi député
et ils accueillaient dans une grande
maison à neuilly plaisance un ancien
forçat devenu le premier compagnon
d'emmaüs
cinquante ans après le mouvement est
présent dans 37 pays quatre continents
mais tout a commencé en région
parisienne reportage patricia charnolé
et hervé pozzo je sais ce que c'est que
la fin j'ai couché dehors j'ai faim j'ai
déjà lé régime allant chez europe
j'ai bu frein c'est parce qu'un homme
l'abbé pierre un jour dit non à la
misère qu'a commencé l'aventuré d'emmaüs
en 1949 la réuni autour de lui les plus
pauvres ceux qu'il a appelés les
chiffonniers puis les compagnons leur
mission récupérer dans les décharges
dans les poubelles les objets jetés par
les autres les réparer et les vendre
aujourd'hui à neuilly plaisance c'est
toujours ce travail de récupération et
de remise en état des structures la vie
de quarante cinq compagnons avant ça
j'étais un petit peu clochard donc
samedi pas différent comme et a
légèrement et ben quand je suis arrivé
je disais que j'avais envie de bosser
gagner mon pain donc sentir utile à
quelque chose
ces oeuvres est le temps qu ils veulent
à emmaüs ils sont logés nourris ils
perçoivent une allocation mensuelle
autour de 1000 francs en échange ils
doivent participer aux activités et ils
ont beaucoup de clients cinq jours par
semaine c'est la vente des objets
réparer elle a un énorme succès l'argent
gagné fait vivre les compagnons et sert
à toutes les autres actions de
solidarité d'emmaüs en france et dans le
monde
un système d'économie solidaire dont la
priorité est le respect de l'homme il ya
des projets qui émergent
et puis il ya le sentiment de contes et
de compter pour tous ceux de la
communauté de compter pour des clients
avec lesquels on a des relations pour
les gens du quartier se rendent compte
qu'on a sa place et là il ya un nouveau
dd des envies personnelles et puis on
retrouve la force de les réaliser et
fournissez le mercado quoi l'histoire
des compagnons est souvent très
douloureuse
pourtant ils sont nombreux à retrouver
ici quelques raisons d'espérer
j'avais un bon métier je gagnais bien ma
vie mais cac 40 a retrouvé du boulot
c'était pas évident du tout et sait
comment à vis ici bien pourquoi je fais
un boulot qui me plaît je m'accorde avec
tout le monde
si vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
retrouvé votre dignité d'homme au
complètement
j'ai beaucoup d'amis en ville j'ai déjà
mis si je peux passer partout la tête
aussi sûr on aime bien ici dans ici à
lui présent son âme game il y en france
4000 compagnons d'emmaüs
preuve que la mobilisation contre
l'exclusion est toujours aussi
nécessaire
mon